following up on all the holiday weekend
news failed former president Donald
Trump did an interview so humiliating
that even his friend Wayne Allen root
couldn't save him Wayne Allen root has
been a guest on this program many times
I encourage you to check out my
conversations with Wayne and you will
probably learn a lot about the type of
person that he is politically he was
interviewed uh sorry he interviewed
Donald Trump uh over the weekend and
we're going to just look at some of it
and it's it's all pretty nauseating to
be perfectly Frank huge fan and
president Trump big fan sir I welcome
you to America's top 10 Countdown with
Wayne Alexander how are you good thanks
Wayne it's great being with you it's
always great being with you we have
we've done some good work together
we have you know you know I'm on your
team by the way the explosive platform
Rumble was able to deliver
27 000 views for this interview geez oh
boy 110 foreign
and my opening commentary which you
haven't even heard yet but I'm sure
you'll get a chance to see a copy of the
show my opening commentary they're gonna
send him a copy of it not the original
they're going to send them a copy was
for this Christmas I want everyone to
appreciate the great gift of President
Donald J Trump because he is our
Braveheart he is our William Wallace if
you remember Mel Gibson's movie
Braveheart it's you fighting against the
Deep State well of course I remember
that movie when and by the way Mel
Gibson was treated totally unfairly by
that Jewish cop completely unfairly
Gibson's was right to ask are you a Jew
and uh listen
sorry what you see swamp and you're the
only thing between them and all of us
being serfs and slaves so we appreciate
you I appreciate you and I I pray to God
you're back again in 24.
well that's really nice and the Rhinos
too you know the rhinos are really bad
in a lot of ways they're worse than the
Democrats right yeah you know where the
Democrats are coming from but these
rhinos that we have and guys like Mitch
McConnell is so bad like this Omnibus
Bill it's not even it's not even
believable they're gonna pass it
horrible it's uh just an incredible
thing it's how he gets away with this
stuff
go ahead I I know you come by the way
the the the talking over each other is
the entire interview on the Omnibus Bill
I saw your comments today his name is
terrible how could Republicans vote for
this why why would Republicans vote for
this because Mitch McConnell raises
money and he gives it to Republican
Senators and they go out and vote very
simply he's not a leader he just raises
money and he gives it you know he pays
gives him a lot of money and it's
amazing you know that they can get that
by because they needed 10 Senators 10 or
12 and he gets the 10 or 12 including
himself to a horrible Bill do you know
on the border security we get nothing
and yet we're giving four or five
countries border security for almost 500
million dollars so they're allowed to
have border security and we're not it's
not even it's not even possible what
they're doing now remember
nobody on the left is saying we can't
have a border or border security there's
just I there's no one on the left is
saying that the point is can we fix
immigration deal with DACA actually
determine what we think we're solving
with a wall realize it won't actually
work and put in place solutions that
make sense the these are straw man
arguments on immigration
but he doesn't he wants to get it done
before the Republican Congress comes in
this is America's top 10 Countdown show
so I come up with the top ten right and
you just covered quite a few of them in
other words I said here's a bill border
security to Middle East countries but
none to ours and his ability gives
another 45 billion to Ukraine but their
Invasion but what about our border
Invasion if title 42 gets lifted what's
gonna happen to America now let's talk
about title 42
title 42 was used by Trump
to more quickly send migrants back to
their home countries okay now the
justification was we have a unique and
explosive Public Health Emergency covet
Trump was simultaneously
downplaying the severity of the pandemic
while saying it is so historically bad
that we need to use title 42 to turn
migrants around and do expedited
deportations
are how wait it's both not super serious
but so serious we need to use something
in a way that it hasn't been used for a
really really long time because it is
such an emergency it was pure politics
that's all it was
well right now it's doing better that we
the weeks of course holding it up
because you know the judges
in our country you know it gets beyond
the legal it gets like it's Common Sense
most of this stuff and uh it'll
certainly be a horrible thing and right
now it's extended to pass the weekend
but you know I was the one that put it
in it was my eyes all right so Trump
both taking credit for criticize so
immigration is a complete and total mess
let's skip ahead to another section just
to give you a little bit of the other
flavor here
yeah no I get it listen I think you're
as loyal as anyone to the Jewish people
in the history of the White House
oh right into it huh nobody's been
better for the Jews than you Don nobody
and I understand your anger and I
understand your questioning why the heck
you're not getting the Jewish vote being
loyal back to you I get it I'm Jewish
and I get it so we've explained it
before
Republicans and their pro-israel view
the way they Define it mostly appeals to
Evangelical Christians not to Jewish
Americans who overwhelmingly vote for
Democrats because on issues Jewish
Americans overwhelmingly line up with
Democrats how many times do we have to
explain this
Jewish vote in 2016 I got 25 of the
Jewish vote and I didn't do it for votes
I did it because it was the right thing
to do then I did Golan Heights which is
a big deal they're trying to get it for
60 years I got it done in 15 minutes I
did Golan Heights which is unbelievably
important but more importantly I did the
embassy I did Jerusalem remember the
embassy what he means is moving the U.S
embassy from Tel Aviv to Jerusalem that
only appeals to right-wing Americans
that's who that appeals to
um
Progressive Jews Like Me recognize
that you can't just unilaterally say
we're putting the embassy in Jerusalem
because it goes right at the heart of
much of the israeli-palestinian conflict
and the sovereignty of Jerusalem and
whether Jerusalem in an eventual
two-state solution which may never come
whether Jerusalem will or won't be the
international capital of Israel over a
hypothetical Palestinian State there's a
reason why
moving the embassy to Jerusalem didn't
make Progressive Jews which is most of
us come scrambling to vote for Trump but
he either doesn't get it or he doesn't
want to accept it becoming the capital
are all great they're all great and then
I did know and then I did the Iran
nuclear deal and terminated it which is
was probably the most valuable thing I
did if you want because they want to
they want to terminate Israel so I did
the Iran nuclear deal and then a guy
calls me up who I know who's been very
good to me big strong guy he was crying
over it he was on Tucker Carlson the
other day a couple of months ago saying
Trump is great and he wanted to have
dinner because I think he needed help
because he needs help but I think he
needed help yeah yeah and all of a
sudden they say oh I'm having dinner
with him and he's an anti-semite now how
am I supposed to know he's an anti if he
is an anti-semite he didn't express that
to me by the way but if he is how was I
supposed to be aware of the major Global
story about Kanye that lasted two weeks
on every news Outlet
we've got to have more loyalty
the Jews should be more loyal to me
Wayne like you yeah no I get it listen
Obama sat in the Pew of an anti-semite
for 20 years giving pictures at his
church Reverend Wright and nobody ever
said a word about it the media liberals
no one you have one dinner with a
stranger and the whole world's against
you all right so anyway I won't do this
the entire thing is 19 minutes long I
think we've had enough of it but a
friendly interview and Trump ends up
with the Jews should be more loyal to me
the Jews should be more loyal to me for
that thing I did where I moved the the
cap at the embassy unbelievable stuff
even Wayne Allen root can't save Trump
over this holiday season please remember
how many families around the world are
living in extreme poverty our partner
give directly is the non-profit letting
you send cash directly to the world's
poorest households help the David
packman show reach our goal of fifteen
thousand dollars by the end of the year
at give directly.org Pacman a generous
give directly donor will match all
donations up to 50 thousand dollars to
help us hit that goal so your donation
can have double the impact giving in
someone's name is a great last minute
holiday gift when organizations give
cash to families like this about 90
cents on the dollar get to the recipient
versus sometimes as little as 50 cents
on the dollar in terms of relative
impact with many other programs that's
why I reached out to give directly about
doing this with us give directly is how
you know every dollar you donate is
going to good use giving even a few
dollars can have a massive impact for
someone living on a dollar or two a day
help us reach fifteen thousand dollars
by December Thirty One and your donation
will be doubled go to give directly.org
Pacman the link is down below